scout association faces backlash over
new
trans fun badge
for members as young as four years old
which have been slammed as inappropriate
i said to myself
what is going on here for four years old
you need four-year-olds now
to put their stamp on this stuff
is this your memory of what the scouts
forget about and believe me we're
talking about this you know scout
association but
what happens in one place trickles out
believe me boy scouts you're going to be
hearing about stuff going on with that
soon too this is just getting everywhere
this woke stuff
but i the the experiences were so
admirable
adventure outdoor adventure all these
skills now this is what it's about you
send your kids to the scouts and this is
what it's about i read the article
scouts interested in buying the trans
fun badge are told and you can scroll
down and see it make a bold statement
with this vibrant scout pride trans
woven badge it's perfect for adding to a
blanket a poncho clothing or a bag to
show your support for scout pride and
the lgbt oh they forgot the cue huh i
don't know about this article must be
bigoted plus community look at the
badges
lesbian fun why do they need a
four-year-old to put this badge on
ask yourself what is going on here even
if you're pro these things right
why do you need a four-year-old to put a
badge on
what is going on here this is now what
it's about
scouting is open to all and welcomes
young people and adults regardless of
their sexuality or gender identity great
okay nobody wants discriminate no sane
person wants discrimination i'm on board
it's important that in scouts everyone
feels welcomed included and valued why
can't that just be because people treat
each other with respect
why can't the message just be hey
everyone's welcome here
we all have differences we all have
preferences everyone's welcome we're
gonna work together we're gonna we're
gonna you know put forth some good
teamwork why does it need to be
announced that i support this where's my
badge i need a badge i'm feeling very
empty today i don't have a sticker
i don't have a pin
i must be in the wrong year maybe i am
in 1985. i got in that delorean after
all tyler
so
this is what i'm saying we got stuff
going on with adults we got stuff going
can't we just
not try so hard to be this for everyone
all the time
this is something you can achieve you
can achieve respect for people and their
individual choices without sticking a
badge on a four-year-old
a four-year-old doesn't know what that
badge means a four-year-old doesn't want
to know what that badge means a
four-year-old wants to play
because they're a child
and you're sticking your adulthood on
that child and forcing them to grow up
and be woke because you need them to be
cut the [ __ ]
caught the [ __ ] really
all right
do you see right after that the scout
association has long expanded beyond
boys only clubs cubs are for girls and
boys aged 8 to 10 and scouts are for
those up to 14. it's new youth section
squirrels which is being funded by the
government go figure
it's shocking shocking
see but isn't it sad right we say this
and we say oh
shocking we're not surprised
we're not surprised when the government
gets involved in this nonsense the
government who by the way takes a [ __ ]
ton of your money that you work hard for
every year and then you find out that
it's being used toward nonsense or stuff
that you're like what this is the job of
the government
priorities are twisted they're real
twisted we started the show out with
twisted priorities with the social media
nonsense and everybody needs to be loved
and needs the stamp of approval
now we're getting into porn then we're
getting into the priorities and i don't
know what's going on at the dinner
tables around this country but parents
better start talking to their kids and
having real conversations with their
kids because kids today are coming into
a in a world where they're expecting
those four-year-olds to have adult minds
and process this stuff if you like the
short clip you can catch another one
here or you can catch the full episode
right here
[Music]